avec les vacances la grande ascension a
commencé sur la dune du pilat chaque
année on compte plus d'un million et
demi de visiteurs le site donc le plus
visité d'aquitaine mais aussi une énorme
masse de sable qui n'arrête pas de se
déplacer reportage david bazié bernard
bonne arme
à la dune du pilat c'est tous les jours
l'étape de montagne
l'ia les grimpeurs les grands baroudeurs
et ceux qui sont avoir fait la dune
c'est ça qui est beau même si essoufflé
c'est très dur à l'arrivée de faire des
commentaires sur la télé je m'entends
c'est le défi de faire et puis est en
contact direct avec la nature une fois
grimpé sur le ventre du monstre de sable
100 mètres au dessus du bassin
d'arcachon la plus belle vue de la
région et du sable du sable du sable sel
boxe que ça y est j'ai fait mon service
militaire au sort c'est pareil ils
seront bien faisant les îles pacifique
magnifique ça plaît tellement que le
site reçoit un million cinq cent mille
visiteurs par an une foule de plus en
plus nombreuses qu'il faut accompagner
chaque saison la commune de la teste
installe son gigantesque et sky il ya
d'autres accès à la lune mais on a
souhaité pouvoir canaliser les visiteurs
de manière à ce que cette ce flux
importants passe par un endroit que l'on
peut organiser entretenir régulièrement
car la dune et surveiller étroitement l
avance de 4 à 5 mètres par an au camping
de la dune le directeur christian bidon
a vu sa piscine disparaître ensevelies
par le sable
voilà nous sommes sur la dune est ici à
la verticale se trouvait la piscine
jusqu'en 1985
on a donc reconstruit la piscine le plus
loin possible de la dune elle nous
nourrit mais elle nous mangent donc
comme nous nourrit bas il faut
l'entretenir il faut la soigner il faut
veiller à son évolution
et puis elle nous mange celle
irréversible c'est l'irrémédiable
irrémédiable mais les études le montrent
ce n'est pas le tourisme qui fait
s'affaisser la dune
c'est la nature